The bad blood between the hosts of "American
Pickers" has been very public, but did you hear
about one cast member's tax scandal? Keep watching
to find out who the IRS had in their sights.
For over 10 years, television viewers have been
captivated by the wacky and crazy finds made on
the History Channel's hit reality show "American
Pickers." Countless items have been discovered
since Mike Wolfe, Frank Fritz, and Danielle
Colby first made their TV debuts in 2010,
and they continue to unearth long-lost family
artifacts and heirlooms to this very day.
Sometimes they have to delve deep into
a stranger's garage to find some hidden
treasure, but whether they locate
old vehicles or antique weaponry,
they always tend to find something worth
a pretty penny. They're masters of sorting
through various memorabilia, but they're not
the only ones who enjoy digging up the past.
Viewers have done the research and
discovered a number of scandals and secrets,
such as the controversial firing of
Fritz and his reported feud with Wolfe,
who is still on the show for its
22nd season. Fritz told The Sun,
"We were never friends in grade school. I
don't believe in 10 years he's said five
nice things to me, you know? Unless he was cutting
somebody else down and we were both laughing."
It seems like a lot of drama for a series
that's essentially about antiquing.
But there's one proverbial black eye on the show
that many fans might not know about — one which
could have potentially landed a cast member
behind bars. And it's not who you think.
Anyone who watches "American Pickers" knows that
Danielle Colby isn't a person who cares too much
about what others think. She's practically covered
in head to toe with tattoos and has gained fame
as a burlesque dancer. She marches to the beat
of her own drum, and that's why fans adore her.
However, if there's one group of people
you don't want to upset, it's the IRS.
According to Radar Online, in 2013 Colby
reportedly received a notice from the IRS
saying she owed nearly $6,000 in taxes. It
seemed particularly odd given that Colby is
allegedly worth roughly $1.5 million thanks
to her earnings from "American Pickers."
The back taxes are reportedly related to the
reality star's burlesque boutique, dubbed "4
Miles 2 Memphis," which received at least four
notices from the feds. Documents obtained by
Radar Online allegedly show that Colby never filed
any returns. In June 2014, she was slapped with a
notice of a lien for $5,936 in estimated retail
taxes for sales that were made in December 2013.
"I'm really greedy with my things."
"My collection is primarily vintage burlesque
and sideshow and circus and striptease costumes."
There's currently no documentation online proving
Colby paid her taxes, but judging from the fact
she's not in federal prison right now, it's
a safe bet that she took care of it. However,
the scandal might be enough to make
some fans worry about Colby's future
on "American Pickers," especially
in light of Frank Fritz's departure.
Fortunately, viewers probably won't have to
say another goodbye any time soon. Colby is
still on "American Pickers" and seems to
enjoy continuing to work with her co-star,
Mike Wolfe. In fact, she posted a photo
of the two of them together on Instagram
in August 2021, where she
spoke highly of his character.
She wrote,
"Thank you for the last decade of
advocacy towards myself and others on set.
@mikewolfeamericanpicker I'm proud of how
you have handled the last 12 years and look
forward to many more years of rolling
around this big blue marble together."
She's been thorough in her efforts to let
the world know that she and Mike Wolfe
are still on good terms. During the Fritz
firestorm, Colby uploaded another photo of
them together on Instagram, writing, quote, "I
love getting to spend time with [Mike Wolfe]."
It definitely seems like she's on Wolfe's good
side, and "American Pickers" fans no doubt hope
she stays there. After the loss of Frank
Fritz, nobody wants to see Colby relegated
to the dustbin of history. Here's hoping she's
paid all her taxes by now, otherwise the next
vintage outfit she might have to pick out for her
boutique could involve black and white stripes.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite celebs are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.